the village of uku in
indian-administered kashmir supplies 90
of the wood used in indian pencils the
moisture levels in the region's poplar
trees make them perfect to write with
but with schools being closed for most
of the past two years demand for
stationary is down and many workers in
uku's factories have lost their jobs
i am a university graduate but there are
no jobs available thank god that we were
hired to work here so many have been
fired in other factories and it's
impossible to get a job in these tough
times
unemployment in india rose to a
four-month high of nearly eight percent
in december that's after most states
imposed restrictions to slow down the
spread of the coronavirus fueled by the
omicron variant
in kashmir the situation is always tense
but the last two years is the first time
schools have been shut in india and
other countries too which has impacted
us badly the business has started to
recover in december but with this new
covet variant we are back to square one
it's a sentiment being shared by
business owners across india
gym owner chirag seti says gyms have
been forced to shut for nine of the past
22 months all the gym owners were
already in a burden of debt okay but now
with this locked down it is actually
breaking down our back because now we
have no money left no bank is giving us
any loan
we have sold the jewelry for our wives
our mothers people have sold jewelry
people have sold their cars people have
begged to borrow whatever they could do
to just survive the last lockdown
despite the downturn the government says
the economy will grow by nearly 10 this
year but economists say it's too early
for optimism i don't think that these
estimates are factored in omicron at all
and so what you're likely to see is that
there will be
a revision in the second advanced
estimate which will come out at the end
of february
which will be downwards and quite maybe
quite seriously downwards depending upon
what happens in the next couple of
months
as the government prepares to release
its budget next month the queues in the
capital of daily wage laborers waiting
with their tools hoping to be selected
for work
keep growing longer elizabeth puranam al
jazeera new delhi